hey guys it's justine and today i
thought i would do a little rumor video
it's been a while since i've done one of
these and i don't really like to do them
because it sort of just promotes more
random rumors
but it is kind of fun to go and see what
people are talking about and what people
think
is going to be released next and this
kind of really hit home for me this
is a render of what potentially could be
the new 2021 imax and this was released
by john prosser
and he's obviously has quite a track
record for releasing a lot of rumors
and leaks and why this got me kind of
particularly excited is because
when these colored imacs were released
this was at a time where apple was kind
of struggling financially
and a lot of things were up in the air
and this sort of
invigorated apple it sort of got people
interested again i guess added the fun
back into the company and then these
computers were wildly used in schools
and you saw them everywhere and it
really kind of
was a game changer for apple and for me
personally
like these colored imacs they do hold a
very special place in my heart so
let's go and see when were these
released so this was the
lifespan of them were from 1998 to 2003.
so this was kind of for me at a point
where i was
actually in high school kind of just
graduating trying to figure out what i
wanted to do
and at that point in time apple had such
a huge influence on me i was doing book
reports on steve jobs i was trying to
figure out what i wanted to do with the
rest of my life and where my interests
lie
and mostly i was very interested in
graphic design and
photography so seeing the success of
these imacs and seeing them basically
everywhere that i went was was really
really cool i do remember we went and
got the lime imac for my grandmother and
it was kind of cool
to sort of introduce her to this whole
world that was something that was so
near and dear to my heart and then to
kind of teach her how to use it and now
my grandmother is so tech savvy like you
guys don't even know like she makes
full-on scrapbooks of all of my
adventures she does them all in pages
she prints them out and it's so
fascinating to see how
far she's come from that lime imac we
actually did recently get her
a new imac for christmas so she is all
up to date
i feel like the color scheme of these
potential imacs are really not that far
off because these are all the colors
basically of the last ipad air and the
colors of the new air pods pro max which
i've been loving my airpods pro max i
just recently got back from a three week
kind of covered safe social distancing
road trip where i basically saw less
people in three weeks than i saw on a
single walk
around my block in los angeles and my
sister and i
were doing podcasts and my sister and i
were doing podcasts basically in the
back of a chevy tahoe
and we've been using the airpods pro max
for our main headphone source
i edited probably 35 hours in the
passenger seat of the car with them
even in the car when we were kind of
having conversations and i was editing i
actually would forget that i had them
on because i would just turn the
transparency mode on and i would be able
to hear everything
perfectly like it's kind of weird to
think about and then i'd be like wait i
have i have a headset on like this is
this is strange but anyway going back to
these imacs i'm
very excited because the performance of
the m1
in that 13 inch macbook pro i'm not
gonna lie
it's basically been my main editing
machine since it came out now
i obviously had traveled a little bit
for the holidays and
this past three weeks the three-week
road trip was really a test for me
because
i pushed this thing to its limits now
the fact that it only does have two
ports is a little bit hindering because
it doesn't have enough power to power
two
of my four terabyte solid state drives
i'd run into a few issues with that but
it's it's like this machine
is not a pro level machine and the
things that i have been doing
on this laptop are just it's
mind-blowing to me i'm editing 8k
footage i'm editing externally i've been
powering our entire podcast i basically
have been doing everything on it and
it's been performing amazing there have
been a few issues that i've run into
where some plug-ins didn't work and
things weren't working properly but i
feel like that's kind of to be expected
because of the whole
entirely new architecture and a lot of
apps have not completely
got on board with m1 yet and also big
sur and for me i usually never update to
the latest os
until like six to eight months later
just to make sure everything works but
this year
i did update to big sur on all of my
machines and
there have been a few instances of
things that haven't worked
i know a lot of people who do a lot with
audio they have not been able to use
various plugins and things like that so
i think it is kind of hit or miss
depending upon what you're doing but for
me that m1
and being completely kind of engulfed in
the apple ecosystem editing and final
cut and compressor
and everything that i do it's so
powerful i mean
it really does rival my mac pro back
there
now the difference is though obviously
with the mac pro i have so much more
power i can attach so many more things
to it i
have 1.5 terabytes of ram in it
so it is kind of hard to put them kind
of side by side in a comparison
kind of in that scale but the amount of
things that i've done on that macbook
pro i just i
i'm so shocked the future
of these chips that apple is creating is
i'm so here for it
like the next whatever they release
whatever it is
if it's gonna be a 16-inch macbook pro i
don't know
i'm so ready for it but that's also why
i'm very excited about the potential
next gen desktop so john also showed
this this is a potential render of what
the new mac pro would be like so i don't
know if you guys can see
well you know what the mac pro looks
like but it's over there it's a big boy
it's beefy it's powerful it's incredible
so the fact that this
is saying that it is gonna be like three
to four
mac minis stacked on top of each other
like that's what it's gonna look like
and it's like processing power here heat
sink up here
what's that top look like though i
wonder i wonder if it's gonna kind of
look like the grill
of the mac pro would be pretty cool so
who knows if it's real but either way i
think these colors do look beautiful but
what's difficult is if this is on my
desk i'm really only gonna see the
screen and kind of like the bottom
of it so i don't really see that much of
a reason to have
all the colors but i do know that i
would definitely be getting the pink one
no questions asked what is the question
what color do you want
don't even need to freaking answer it
it's answered already
the thing that i don't like though is my
only
sort of complaint is uh this color
of the airpods pro max like i don't like
this it's a little too orange
like this is nice i feel like this
should have been more of like a muted
kind of color
because it doesn't really match anything
like it's just it's not i don't i'm not
sure
i don't it's too it's just it's it's a
miss for me
that's all i'm gonna say but like this
color pink like this is nice look at
that look at this
nice but this color pink on the imac is
probably gonna be more like this kind of
uh
a color which is nice i like this this i
like this this is orange this isn't even
pink this is nothing this is not even
i don't i just i'd love to hear from you
guys though like what are you looking
forward to apple this year have you seen
any of the rumors that i should check
out
i'm just very excited about the future
of what the m1 chips are going to be
because seeing the power and the
potential just in these lower end
macbooks
it has me so excited for the future i'll
see you guys in my next video feel free
to leave me some comments below
don't forget to like and subscribe and
hit the bell so you're notified
when i post new videos and that's all
i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]
bye